sur internet de succès d'un nouveau site
appelé facebook un site de socialisation
qui annonce 50 millions d'inscrits dans
le monde et qui a de plus en plus
d'adeptes en france novembre 2007 la
france découvre facebook ainsi créé
trois ans plus tôt aux états unis par un
certain mark zuckerberg étudiants à
harvard 24 ans en 2004 il bidouille
ainsi dans sa chambre son objectif
relier tous les étudiants de son
université
rapidement tous les campus américains se
retrouvent en ligne et en mai dernier il
ouvre son réseau social au monde entier
et devient un phénomène de société deux
cent mille nouveaux inscrits par jour
c'est clair facebook c'est l'attraction
web du moment 50 millions de personnes
utilisent ce trombinoscope virtuel et
c'est pas près de s'arrêter car
l'objectif est clair pour mark
zuckerberg
je ne sais pas si un jour on aura toute
l'humanité sur notre réseau mais je
pense qu obtenir quelques centaines de
millions d'utilisateurs en plus et mon
prochain objectif
objectif atteint le nombre d'abonnés est
exponentielle et les profils facebook
possible si bien qu'en 2012 l'entreprise
entre en bourse à 28 ans mark zuckerberg
a star de la silicon valley bas à
nouveau record à 104 milliards de
dollars facebook est la plus grosse
introduction en bourse depuis la
création d'internet
le réseau social créé il y a huit ans
rassemble aujourd'hui 900 millions de
personnes sur la planète une ascension
fulgurante des chiffres qui donnent le
tournis et l'entreprise s'agrandit pour
un milliard de dollars facebook achète
en 2012 instagram puis en 2014 ouattara
19 milliards de dollars le prix payé par
facebook pour acheter whatsapp un
système de messagerie instantanée la
somme paraît folle mais c'est un choix
stratégique pour reconquérir les jeunes
reconquérir les jeunes c'est tout
l'enjeu de facebook ces dernières années
car l'entreprise se ringardise et fait
face à des scandales sur l'utilisation
des données personnelles de ses abonnés
en mars dernier facebook est emporté par
le scandale cambridge analytique à un
vol massif de données de milliers
d'utilisateurs américains qui auraient
servi à la campagne présidentielle de
donald trump
mais facebook n'aurait pas trompé que
ses utilisateurs
ces publicitaires perdre aussi confiance
une confiance ébranlée également par les
fake news relayé sur facebook si bien on
commence à se demander si après des
années à l'hégémonie incontesté lempire
de mark zuckerberg serait t'il ébranlé
c'est toute la question car pour la
première fois de son histoire facebook a
perdu des abonnés et sa valeur a chuté
de 25 pour cent à la bourse de new york
au début du mois de février 2022
mais facebook reste toujours un empire
avec près d'un tiers de la population
mondiale qui est inscrite et que
l'entreprise compte bien séduire avec
son nouveau monde virtuel
metaverse
e